the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so I'm going to give you a quick example
of what I think is a good way to do
solutions our approach to solutions
state the problem and give you a little
formulaic here draw figures on the first
day I said I'd like to think of dynamics
problem I break them down into three
categories one is to describe the motion
now what is describing the motion mean
well how many the number of degrees of
freedom in the problem that implies the
number of equations of motion that
you're going to need to solve that
problem so you've got to identify the
number of degrees of freedom it also
then tells you the number of coordinates
you need so this is all part of
describing the motion it's figuring out
how many coordinates assigning them
so assigning the coordinates and then
finally essentially all underneath this
you essentially do the kinematics and
that's the velocities accelerations so
forth
so once you have you've explained the
motion and this I guess it's for explain
the correct physical laws you know how
they apply F equals MA
Newton's first second third law or
conservation of momentum whatever you
want you think is the appropriate thing
so explain what your what the physical
laws are and apply them and finally do
the math so if you can break problems
down that way it'll give you a nice
logical flow so I'm going to give you a
bit of an example problem
and I'm also going to kind of pose a
brainteaser to you at the end of this
problem today I want you to give you
something to think about so I'm going to
draw my problem this is a block on an
incline it's got some scales to measure
your weight and you're standing on this
thing riding it down the incline okay
and the first question about this is to
find the position as a function of time
so that's the problem that's part a so
state the problem find the position
so how do we do well draw figures I've
started with that next describe the
motion I need a frequent we have to
figure out how many degrees of freedom
this problem has I'm going to just
declare no rotation going to treat it as
a particle so a particle has how many
generally how many degrees of freedom
how many coordinates to completely
describe where it's at three okay so I
may need as many as three coordinates to
describe the motion of this thing
and if I really doing complete equations
of motion I need three equations of
motion so this is two three describing
the motion I have three degrees of
freedom I'm going to need three
coordinates so in this case here's my
picture I'm going just to set up a
Cartesian coordinate system aligned in a
helpful way X Y Z coming out and this is
my fixed inertial reference frame and
here's my center of mass and basically
my coordinates are describing the
position of the center of mass
okay so that's pretty much the
describing the motion what I need for
now we'll get to the velocities and
accelerations when we get to the math
part apply the physics well I'm going to
use Newton's second law some of the
external forces mass times the
acceleration that's the physical law by
going I'm going to apply draw a Freebody
diagram
and I'm just going to consider the block
and the person this is the whole
collection it's one thing I'm just not
keep drawing the person on it but so
here's my object including the weight of
the person and it's going to have here's
its center of mass obviously an mg a
gravitational force it's going to have a
normal force it's going to have a
friction force and how do I figure out
what the friction which Direction
friction is I assume motion down the
hill friction will oppose it I draw in
the arrows in the direction I expect the
forces to act and I'll use a sign
convention that the arrows tell me what
signs so since my x-coordinate is down
the hill this is y this is X friction
acts in the minus X direction okay and I
haven't I've left out a key piece of
information got to have the angle of the
slope and once you have the angle of the
slope that's theta this is Theta and I'm
going to need to this is in a direction
of one of my coordinates and so's this
but I need to break the gravitational
piece into components lined up with my
coordinates and so you have a theta here
as well and now I can write my equations
of motion and the nice thing about
vectors is that when you have three
equations of motion three coordinates
each are components of vectors in the x
y&z directions it gives us three
equations immediately so for example the
summation of the forces in this problem
in the Z direction the external forces
our sums to zero okay so we get a
trivial solution out of that and we
don't have to go much further summation
of the forces in the y-direction gives
us some useful information and in the Y
directed forces I have an N and a minus
mg and is it I think it's cosine theta
which tells me immediately what n is
so from statics I get to and from what
we know about models of friction then we
know that we can model the friction as
mu times n mu and G cosine theta okay so
from the statics like I learned a bunch
of things that I need to know for the
problem so now I get to the real
harder the problem writing my equation
of motion in the X direction and the
forces in the X direction mg sine-theta
down the hill so it's positive minus the
friction is up the hill so I get mg mix
it up my am's here but there's no other
M so
and this basically says that x
double-dot the MS all cancel out that x
double-dot is G sine theta minus mu G
cosine theta and that half that just
happens to be a pretty simple to solve
ordinary differential equation this is
an equation in which the acceleration
and the problem is constant theta is not
changing none of these things are
changing and so you can just solve this
one now we did the third part do the
math this one you can just integrate and
so you find out that well x dot then and
I'm just going to call this C some
constant so X dot CT plus an initial
velocity if it had one and X of T what
you're looking for and now so V naught
and X naught are just your initial
conditions
more than likely zero if you set it up
cleverly so that's just sort of modeling
quickly kind of what I I think a good
way to layout a problem is describing
the motion explaining the physics doing
the math drawing good pictures stating
the problem alright so now the
brainteaser that i want you to think
about
so here's the mass of the block plus the
scales and here's the hair you're
standing on it so mass of the person
you're riding this down the hill this is
Part B
think about that one in the shower if
you've got a really simple way to do it
great write it up it's not terribly hard
and it's mostly give you a hint thinking
in terms of Freebody diagrams helps a
lot and we'll come back to this kind of
fun problem
okay I want to go that's that was that
part one I want to go on to the
recapping the center-of-mass quickly we
learned a couple of important things we
got we talked about the center of mass
because we were just talking about
Newton's three laws from looking at the
first law found that it's useful to
determining whether or not you're an
inertial frame we used it second law
we've just applied it we used to do get
equations of motion third law was about
we used it when we're thinking about
center of mass we use it to define what
the center of mass was so we said the
total mass of a system a better drama
picture here's my system of particles m1
with position vectors home s of
particles with their position vectors
this is RI with respect to O for example
this is my o XYZ frame we said this
total mass of the particles somewhere
out here there's a center of mass with a
position vector R G with respect to O so
the definition of Senet my center of
mass is this is equal to the summation
of the mi RI OS and these vectors are
position vectors so that's the
definition of my center of mass if I
take two time derivatives of that we
arrived at mt RG with respect to o
double dot the summation over i of my m
i are i o double dots okay and then
importantly that's summation
of all of the external forces on each of
these each one of these by itself
satisfies Newton's law second law which
he wrote about particles each one has a
summation I've summed these I'm going to
sum these but each one has a summation
of internal forces acting on it these I
called the F I J's and we learn
something about the third law tells us
about that summation the third law tells
us what that that goes to zero and that
was the that's the really powerful piece
of third law that we make great use of
because this now essentially allows us
to say that the summation of the
external forces on an assembly of
particles on a system of particles is
equal to the total mass times the
acceleration of the center of mass and
that what that does in one stroke takes
you from Newton who was a Dru's laws
applied to particles and allows you to
apply Newton's second law to rigid
bodies because rigid bodies can be
thought up of a bunch of particles which
are represented in that simple equation
and that gets you from particles to
rigid bodies and we all know from
physics that the summation of the
external force on this thing is the mass
times the acceleration of the center of
mass right okay so that's actually quite
an important powerful lie it provides
this for us
now I said I wanted to give you a quick
very useful application of thinking
about center of mass I showed you the
other day I had my carbon fiber tube
here showed you that trick for finding
the center of mass just by sliding your
fingers along it right and you end up at
the center of mass
well as a practical matter other things
you really want to be able to find
center of masses this is a glider a sail
plane : l s8 i happened if i'm a fly my
glider flight instructor been flying
gliders for 35 years or something like
that and i flew a glider of this type
just recently that that machine has a
forty nine to one let's call it 50 don't
want to make it easy glide ratio means
if you're mile above the ground in still
air you will go fifty miles before you
touch the ground so they're really
amazing high-performance machines one of
the things about all aircraft that you
actually need to know is you really need
to know where the center of mass of it
is and if the center of mass is in the
wrong place the plane will not fly
properly and so you can't just go throw
in fifty pounds of lead and the tail of
that plane and expect to survive the
next flight so you have to know where
the center of mass is and in fact you
want the center mass about 25% of the if
the wing is this wide from front to back
it's called the cord about 25% back from
the leading edge is about where the
center of lift of a set of a wing is and
you want your center of mass also called
the center of gravity in these
situations you want it to be pretty
close to the center of lift so that
they're balanced and the plane flies
nicely so is there a simple way to find
the
center of mass is something like a sail
plane so I got a drip this is practice
exactly how you do it so I'll draw a
quick picture of my sail plane here you
have a little skid or tail wheel in the
back and find the center of mass you
just set them on scales you weigh it you
pick a coordinate system doesn't matter
where it is as long as it's fixed the
easiest place is right at the nose of
the sail plane so we'll make this X make
this Y you take it and you can take a
tape measure and measure the distance
from your reference point to the
position where the wheel sits on the
scales we'll call that L 1 here and
that's typically about five feet and
back here you have another position to
where you have your second set of scales
that's L 2 and a typical sail plane
that's about 15 feet apply Newton's law
this thing's not going anywhere
some of the forces in the vertical
direction is equal to zero
Freebody diagram well you have somewhere
about here where the wing is this is
your center of mass and you have M total
times G downwards there you have two
weights pushing on the sail plane a w-2
pushing up holding up the tail and a w1
holding up the main gear and so from the
sum of the forces in the y-direction
that it better be zero so you know that
W 1 plus W 2 minus M T G 0 and so you
find out that the total weight of the
sailplane is no surprise the sum of the
two weights on the scales e yeah let's
do this
MTG okay so the total weight times
gravity is just a sum of the two
readings on the scales and the second
piece that you need to do to do this
problem is you have a equation that says
the sum of the external torques with
respect here to a fixed point O is equal
to the mass moment of inertia times the
angular acceleration often times written
as alpha in this case that's going to be
0 it's going nowhere
okay so what are the external torques
with respect to this point well we have
a right handed coordinate system if w1
up times l1 w2 up times l2 minus w1 plus
w2 which is a total weight of the
sailplane
times our G the location of the center
of mass of the center of mass that's
this distance that we're looking for
so we can we know everything here except
our G so we can solve for our G with
respect to O and it's simply W 1 L 1
plus W 2 L 2 over W 1 plus W 2 and if
you run the numbers typically W 1 600
pounds W 2 the numbers I've done here is
might be 40 pounds and I've already said
five feet and 15 feet and you work the
answer and you come up with five point
six two feet which puts this you know
here was yours a wheel and you're a
little bit aft of the main gear and
that's where you basically where you
want to be so that's a real practical
use of knowing about centers of mass and
how to calculate them okay so that's the
second item I want to talk about today
since your recap of the center of mass
and now I want to move on to talking
about sort of it serious introduction to
or we've had the introduction velocities
and accelerations we have to have a way
of writing down the acceleration of a
mass a point a dog in a rotating
translating reference frame with the
possibility that in addition to that
that are moving so we want to have
equations we want to have the ability to
write down expressions for the velocity
and acceleration of a mass moving
in a translating rotating reference
frame so we've started this we did
pretty much did velocities to begin with
you
so here's my inertial frame call it o or
o XYZ here's my rigidbody out there as a
point a something else that B might be
the dog and we've described the position
of this as the position of this point a
with respect to O and at this point
we're going to locate a reference frame
attached to the rigidbody and so it's
going to be called a and I'll call it X
prime Y prime Z prime it's attached to
the rigidbody it rotates with a
rigidbody and it's attached at just some
fixed point
now what would often times would be a
smart choice for that fixed point at
Point a
if you're going to write an equation
expressing the motion of this where
would you make point a center mass right
so very very often especially when
objects are free floating around out
there you're going to make smart choices
you going to put this wrote this
coordinate system right on the center of
mass but it doesn't have to be but it
can be okay so we we're interested in
knowing things about the motion of this
point in our initial reference frame in
terms of positions of our coordinate
system and then also this vector here
our B with respect to a now last time we
came up with expressions for the
velocity of B with respect to O we said
in general it's the velocity of your or
your coordinate systems located the
translating the velocity of the
translating frame plus the derivative of
R be a time derivative of the position
as seen from if you were sitting at a
and another way to say that or this is a
derivative taken with the rotation rate
momentarily set equal to zero another
way to think of it plus a peace that
comes from rotation so the rotation with
respect to the fixed frame these are all
vectors the rotation with respect to the
fixed frame cross product with RBA and
this and we said this is actually a
general formula for the derivative of
this piece is the derivative of a vector
in a frame
in a fixed frame you have two pieces the
derivative as seen without rotation plus
the contribution that comes from
rotation
when I did this center of mass thing a
second ago I just kind of quickly wrote
down to turret time derivative of the
position vector
there's no Amega across those or in
there right how why could I do that
this is actually kind of an important
gist it
they didn't say very specifically when I
did it an assumption I was making except
that perhaps they drew it this was done
in a Cartesian coordinate system and my
coordinates were XY and Z and the unit
vectors were ijk and do they move no
what's their time derivative okay when
you don't when the unit vectors don't
have time derivatives you don't get
these terms this is the only term to
contribute so I could just write that
equation but we now have a reference
frame attached to a body and this
reference frame is rotating and that
means that the direction of the unit
vectors attach the unit vector attached
to X prime here is moving this rotating
and it's going to have a time derivative
so we have to D and that is given and
take those time derivatives you get this
second piece alright I'm going to give
you the answer in advance the
acceleration of B with respect oh I'm
going to give you the full 3d equation
then we'll go back in C a bit where it
comes from
so here's it's the time derivative of
that velocity expression with respect to
time taken in the inertial frame Oh XYZ
and I'm going to enough a room to get
this on beat close all right this has
several pieces it's got a contribution
of the acceleration of a with respect to
oh that's just the acceleration of this
point has nothing to do with rotation so
it's just a straight-out acceleration of
my translating frame with respect to oh
that's the first piece the second piece
is related is the derivative of this guy
there comes from the derivative of this
it's the acceleration of B with respect
to a as seen in this a frame okay can
you read the Williams book it's called
the relative acceleration it's relative
to the if you were sitting at Point a
it's what you would see is the
acceleration okay plus two Omega cross
velocity of B with respect to a as seen
from A plus Omega dot the derivative of
the rotation rate cross R b/a plus Omega
cross Omega cross R b/a
kind of daunting right little messy
basically one two three four five
different terms and you're going to and
they all have names and meanings and one
of the things that will really help you
is to get familiar you really need to be
familiar with the meaning of each one of
the terms it's not terribly difficult
this one's just the acceleration of the
translating frame so if it's a
merry-go-round sitting on a train and
the trains heading down the track its
acceleration of the Train rotating frame
is attached to the merry-go-round so and
if you've got the dog on the
merry-go-round this is then the
acceleration of the dog relative to this
the merry-go-round this position of the
coordinate system attached to the
merry-go-round has no rotation in it
this is this is the velocity of that
point the dog as seen from the a-frame
again you have no sense of rotation
rotations not a part of this
cross-product with the rotation rate
this is the accelerate this is the
angular acceleration cross product with
RBA now that's a term what does that
mean you know if I'm swinging a baseball
bat I'm accelerating this thing predict
you idealize it as just um something on
a radius accelerating the acceleration
of a point out here is the radius times
the angular acceleration so that's all
this term is that's and it's called the
Euler acceleration but it's just simply
our theta double dot okay
this if you'd multiply it out and just
think about units this ends up looking
like R Omega squared have you run into
that before what's that
common language as a decimal centrifugal
centripetal this is centripetal
acceleration so this is the extent
rippable acceleration term that's the
Euler acceleration term this is the
local acceleration that's the
acceleration of your frame this is the
strange one this is the Coriolis
acceleration and we'll get familiar with
it too so that's the that's the
full-blown 3d acceleration equation and
by the way the vector the velocity one
is also perfect 3d now in this course we
won't do much in the way of 3d dynamics
problems yes the rigid plane does the
hidden a it could be this is a you know
an asteroid out there in space and
you've got this is home base and that's
guy out there in a spacesuit running so
we want to be able to describe the
acceleration of that guy as seen from a
fixed reference frame now why would we
want to know that acceleration Nix and
why do we want to know it in a fixed
frame well if you want to calculate the
forces on the person like well how much
what's it what's you have to do with his
feet the brace himself or whatever what
are the actual forces you have to know
the acceleration on the person but
Newton's laws in order to say F equals
MA Newton's laws have to be applied in
inertial reference frames is this thing
out there doing this an inertial
reference frame no so you can't
calculate the forces without having some
idea of this inertial frame so this is
the way of getting the acceleration on
at a location
on a moving rotating body with respect
to an inertial frame in with all the
terms present now most this course
generally has addressed problems which
are in the in most textbooks dress only
planar motion problems planar motion
basically means that we confine the
translations to a plane so imagine an X
Y and a Z upwards coordinate system
attached to the top of this table and I
only allow motions that are around the
table and I only allow motions that have
a single acts of rotation and that's
lined up with Z those essentially planar
motion problems and most both courses
and dynamics at lists so well that's as
far as they get and for the most of the
problems that you'll do will be planar
motion problems but that equation you
know reduces to the planar motion
problem as well we will do a little bit
of 3d because there's a class of
problems that I really think it's
important for you to understand that
just come up all the time that require a
little 3d and as you want to have some
things going on out of the plane but
we'll still confine the axis of rotation
to a single direction yeah
that's a great question she saved a dog
running on the merry-go-round how many
degrees of freedom do you have so in
general
rigid bodies each rigid body each
independent rigid body has you have to
describe its location of its center of
mass and that takes how many coordinates
how many coordinates alcohol well in
general three okay and it can now rotate
around three different axes and that
takes three more so rigid bodies have
six degrees of freedom
and any problem when you go to address
the problem you essentially if a rigid
body you start with six and you start
applying constraints to reduce it down
to the number of remaining degrees of
freedom so if it's confined to a plane
and noisy motion is allowed one
constraint if it is on a plane and it's
only allowed to rotate about the z axis
that means you've constrained its
rotation in around Y and X so that's two
more and so now you're down to three
degrees of freedom left X Y and a
rotation about the z axis so planar
motion problems generally have three
degrees of freedom but it's instant
let's just say we're just interested in
just something that rotates and doesn't
translate how many degrees of freedom
does that have then just one accent why
is it forced not to know motion to more
constraints you're down to one so lots
of problems we do are in fact single
degree of freedom problems okay
so to do planar motion problems we
oftentimes use polar coordinates so I'm
going to enter it you know R theta R Z
and we're actually going to call it
cylindrical coordinates and cylindrical
coordinates then you have an R a theta
and Z and let's think of it well let's
see I have a demo a little demo here so
here's a here's a problem with a single
axis of rotation but and it's a there's
a mass out here and just this is a rod
and so think of this think of this mass
out here is being a bug walking out this
rod and the rod this thing can go round
and round it's not a merry-go-round it's
a merry-go-round with the gangplank on
it and the it's going up in an angle and
you know you can walk the gangplank
while the merry-go-rounds going around
that's what so that's what we got here
so this is so this is actually allowed
to change position this mass okay so how
would I describe that with cylindrical
coordinates let me so it's going to take
a cup 1 1 would be a side view so you
see your vertical axis here you can have
to have a bearing to hold it in place
here's the arm here's the bug walking
out the arm has some rotation rate theta
dot this is the z-axis all right
and the position of this point is
described by our vector in the R hat
direction which I think is the unit
vectors you're used to using and then
this is the Z component in the K hat
direction okay and this vector here
would be R of B with respect to what
shall I call it I'll make this a and
over here someplace I have a fixed
inertial let's see it'll be careful here
I want that to be Z then I have a Y
going out here X Y Z pointing upwards
and my this fixed inertial system the
unit vectors here this would be I hat J
hat and k hat but these the this
rotating system with its unit vector
little K and this vector they're the
same they're parallel but looking down
on this this is my polar coordinate
system now I'm going to look at my top
for you I will see a projection I'll
just see the our this is our our hat
this is my point B this is Theta okay
and I have a unit vector so the unit
vector R hat is something unit long
pointing in this direction and the unit
vector in this direction is theta hat
and it's perpendicular to that radius
right
so now I have my three unit vectors one
pointing in direction of our here's also
my unit vector is just to make sure
there's no confusion this unit vector is
in this direction K is in that direction
theta is in that direction okay and over
here you still have here now here's my X
Y Z out of the board inertial frame and
this you know in my inertial frame this
might be our B oh right so in my
inertial frame I want to know what's
going on here
I want to be able to calculate
velocities and the accelerations so the
notation here gets can get a little
confusing the our Bo notation that I've
been using all along that's the motion
that's the position vector describing
that point in my inertial frame and my
just lowercase R here no subscripts or
anything that's just going to that's my
polar coordinate R theta and Z that
happened to be in this case this is a
rotating frame this is a rotating frame
it's the center of this coordinate
systems at a but this thing rotates okay
so this is a pretty simplified version
of this general problem okay it's it's
it because it's simplified you can
actually it's a lot easier to use also
has some real limitations you can only
just discuss their limited things that
you can describe with it
so let's start by describing velocities
in cylindrical coordinates
this RBA is the length of this guy here
and it's made up of our our hat ZK hat
so to express the velocity we have to
take a time derivative of this RBA and
I'm going to express it in terms of our
theta and Z and to get accelerations I
have to take two time derivatives of
this but this is going to be expressed
in my cylindrical coordinates so this is
where I'm going and lots of problems
many many of these problems have fixed
axes of rotations and this velocity in
this acceleration are zero and you just
drop it out we're going to I'm going to
do that just to keep this make this
problem a little simpler so we can just
focus on these terms okay so let's just
let the cordon they translate the there
be no translation of this frame and that
says that V a with respect to O the
acceleration of a with respect to O or
zero so I want to just focus on these
terms I don't lose anything and put
these back in later if I need them I
just don't want to keep care animal
so I have my remember my sideview this
is our R hat ZK hat my point in my top
view
this is my projection just looking down
on it what I see is the lengths are and
what I see in my unit vector going that
way our direction in theta hat direction
okay and this is X and the I and Y with
a J hat vector looking down on it my
rotation rate Omega with respect to my
inertial frame is someth a 2 dot k hat
alright so now let's find the velocity
of B with respect to O well it's 0 no
translation + and now I need a time
derivative of RB with respect to a but
so this is then RBA is our R hat plus Z
K hat and I need the time derivative of
that so I get an r dot R hat plus an R R
hat dot plus AZ K right so this is the
product of two things
they're both time dependent so I have to
get two pieces
K does not change in direction so it has
no time derivative so I only have a ZK
so this is the result of doing this but
I now have to figure out what is the
time derivative of the unit vector in
the r direction
so when I told when I worked out this
formula the other day for the time
derivative of a rotating vector I mostly
did it it was kind of an intuitive
argument so on this one occasion I'm
going to give you an example of actually
figuring out what the derivative of this
rotating vector is and if you go read
that kinematics our handout and it does
this in kind of full-blown form for in
general so I'm just going to do it as
one example so here's our looking down
on this the projection on the XY plane
here's our R vector and here's this unit
vector and it starts from I have a unit
vector starting from a it's unit it's
one long and this is our hat it's a unit
length right and it's in this particular
direction now in a little bit of time
delta T it moves it moves to here so
this is Delta R hat and it what
direction does it move yeah moves in the
moves in the theta hat direction
okay and the amount that it moves is the
rotation rate theta dot delta T all
right so Delta R hat if I solve for this
delta T and this is in the theta hat
direction is theta dot theta hat
so this is the limit as T delta T goes
to zero you get the derivative of our
hat with respect to time it's Direction
is in the theta hat direction and it's
magnitude is Theta dot so that's that's
the time derivative of the unit vector R
hat yep how does it work with units
what's left out of here is that this is
unit length and has dimensions you know
it's unit length one whatever unit
system you're working right so that is
implicitly in here it's one meter theta
dot and that Delta beta dot the delta T
the x go away you're left with one meter
times the magnitude of theta dot so the
distance it actually moves is R theta R
Delta Theta Delta theta is theta dot
delta T and the radius happens to be one
right so whatever unit system you're
working in it's a unit vector as unit
length it's so it's units are buried
right there good question okay so now
we've now we know what this is so now we
can come back finish our description of
the velocity of B with respect to a then
is our dot R hat plus z dot k hat plus
theta dot times so the R times the
derivative of of the unit vector R which
we just figured out is theta dot theta
hat times our R theta dot
theta hat so that's my velocity of B
with respect to a my velocity of B with
respect to all you have to add in is the
velocity of a with respect to which
we've let B zero for now so for the
moment this also V with respect to O but
this is the general piece of the
velocity of B with respect to a in polar
cylindrical coordinates now we could
have so I've actually worked it out just
showing you just draw the picture and
figured out the derivative we could have
used that magic formula write the
formula for the derivative of a vector
in a rotating frame
so the I'll just do that quickly to
remind you how we could have done this
RBA with respect to time
as seen in the oh frame right is the
partial derivative of our be a with
respect to time as seen in the rotating
frame plus Omega cross R b/a all right
this term is that and that the
derivative of this RBA
as seen from inside of the rotating
frame is just the change in length this
is our VA here from the side it's the
change in length of that vector the
derivative of the time derivative of it
it's the vector sum of the r dot plus Z
dot so this piece comes from is this and
this and this piece should this one here
it better be this well this is let's
figure it out this is Omega in the K hat
direction cross and RBA is our R hat
plus Z K hat K cross K is zero K cross R
they too had K cross our K hat cross our
hat is theta hat positive right R Omega
theta hat same thing as R theta dot
theta hat so we could have just applied
this formula for the derivative of a
rotating vector and we would have gotten
the same thing
okay just ran out of boards
now quick little exercise you can do on
your own is we're going to need to be
able to calculate the derivative of
theta hat once it plug it in that little
final formula and the first term you'll
find out the derivative of the theta hat
the length doesn't change in time it's a
unit vector so you only have the second
piece so it's somos mega cross theta
you're going to get minus theta dot R
hat
so I really want to get here the
acceleration of B and O that's the real
that's the single piece we really need
to finish the kinematics so we can do
most any problems got to be able to
describe the acceleration of a point in
translating rotating frame and that's
going to be the acceleration of a with
respect to O plus a time derivative of
the velocity of B with respect to O
we've calculated the velocity we need to
be able to essentially carry out this
derivative to time derivatives of the R
b/a or a single time derivative of VBA
well we just computed the velocity in
this row of this rotating frame and this
is our final expression so we need to
compute the time derivative of that I
just so it's going to look like r dot R
hat plus over here a term R theta dot
theta hat and pardon me for doing this
I think it'll in be cleaner in the end
I'm going to start with my Z dot K keep
it over here plus r dot R hat plus this
term
and this is going to take up a lot of
room just spread out this way and so
let's okay so let's just go write down
how or this comes out this is little
tedious but then you'll have seen it
once
hopefully believe that it really works
okay so these terms this first term here
just gives you Z double dot so let's
write it down so this is Z double dot k
hat times derivative of this plus an R
double dot R hat but now I have to take
it do it to flip it and do the other
side of it so I get my
I want to do this
yeah like this
so this term leads to this this term
brings you to here this term you get an
r dot times theta dot theta hat plus an
R and now you need to take a time
derivative of theta dot theta hat so
that's going to expand so this brings
you to here
but now we net we've done this
derivative so we can put it in so this
gives us
all right
this term over here so let's keep adding
these up
notice this gives me an r dot theta dot
theta hat this gives me an r dot theta
dot theta hat okay to sum two identical
terms now this term gives me an r theta
double dot theta hat and now this now we
need to take the derivative of theta hat
and that gives you minus theta dot R hat
so you get a minus R but multiplied by
theta dot again squared R hat so I think
we're about there we're going to start
collecting things together
now we have a to r dot theta dot theta
hat plus an r theta double dot theta hat
minus r theta dot squared R hat so these
things these derivatives just all kind
of flowed down and led to more terms but
now if we compare that we got one two
three four five i clump these together
this is the change in length of the r
vector the stretch in the position has a
z component and our component this is
the movement of the coordinate system if
it moves this is the Coriolis term this
is the Euler acceleration and this is a
centripetal acceleration so this is the
what happens when you start with that
messy vector thing and apply it restrict
it to a cylindrical coordinate problem
which is basically planar planar motion
but you allow some some things in the Z
direction only so polar coordinates is a
more limited form of that but it so
every term comes back every term is
still in it so acceleration of the
moving coordinate system change of
length of the position vector in the
moving coordinate system the Coriolis
term the Euler acceleration term that
angular acceleration speed up and
finally the centripetal term now the way
you go about solving problems using
doing problems in polar coordinates now
you're asked to find an equation of
motion
this is an expression for the
acceleration of whatever it is you're
trying to describe in an inertial frame
so that when you say you can now say F
equals MA but if you know the sometimes
you're given the forces in problems and
you're asked to find the accelerations
right but what if you're given the
acceleration and you're asked to find
the force all right I'll give you the
simplest problem of this kind what's the
tension in the string well if I know
that so I just say we the way you do
these problems is how many things can
you eliminate well I wasn't moving this
term goes away that's zero Z wasn't
involved it's not changing or just
constant angular rotation that term is
zero what's the change in length of the
string while I was doing it now that
term zero was getting easier all the
time how far how fast was the length
getting longer hmm that would that terms
gone away was i speeding up or slowing
down or constant speed we'll say it's
constant speed oh is probably getting
easier all time I'm down to one term F
equals MA minus R theta dot squared R
hat so the force that I must have been
applying to the string was in the minus
R hat direction and had magnitude M R
Omega squared okay so that's actually
that's all there is to it we using polar
coordinates and cylindrical coordinates
to do second law problems so this couple
of problems that you're going to doing
these kind of things on the homework set
that's being put out today so give them
a try have a good weekend